you know what's so funny we were talking
about like looking at a book when you
were a kid and wanting to read it did i
ever tell you that i have synesthesia
yeah dude he told me this is insane i
told you we talked about this this is
where you like you see colors he said
it's so casually yeah
like a number
or something like that yeah
dude i don't know if you've seen new
euphoria we don't see color anymore at
all like
but he yeah it to me [ __ ] on i think
it was kanye said he has synesthesia and
he was like big [ __ ] deal i didn't
make a genus i have synesthesia and i
was like explain this explain this as
synesthesia it's a man it's different
for each person but it's when your brain
is developing you have senses and as
your brain develops they split well for
people with synesthesia those senses
overlap so they cross wired so you have
unprovoked association to
for me it's letters and number
they all have a color to them so every
letter has a color and every number has
a color to it so when i was little and
i'd read everything was just color
and even music has colors like the
number five is like dark it's not quite
blue but it's the darkest color eight
and five are the darkest color i have
twelve that's like white red because two
is red so four is bright cause it's
yellow eighteen it's like dark very dark
gray on the left side and then dark
black on the right side and then
nineteen brightens up because nineteen's
orange and then 20 is red so it starts
to brighten up so is this how you know
dudes are legal
it's like 18 is a little gray area
19. i don't go below 25. is that true oh
a mess interesting yeah yeah i heard
it's not as looked down as upon if gay
dudes sleep with like a little bit
underage guys
uh sounds like scrutinized in the in the
community it's almost like a 16 year old
dude like banging his female teacher i
mean i saw a man in his early hundreds
the other day walking around with some
twink who probably just turned 19 and i
thought uh good for them both
they're both getting what they want out
of this yeah you know
the smartest man in the world daniel
tammet that he has what you're talking
about he remembered pie to 22 000 places
and the way he described it was like if
you looked at like watercolors of
mountains and blah blah blah it's like
the colors and the dips the valleys and
the tops allow him to remember it that
much
that's how i learned languages so
quickly you have those
yeah the languages it was so easy to
learn languages because especially with
romance language you just start seeing
the same color pattern so i'd hear the
same color right and i would know what
they were asking interesting so crazy
dude
so you speak languages better when you
were high
i don't really haven't gotten high that
much smoke weed ever no interesting i
know i look at because i have those like
dopey italian eyes so i always look high
but i'm like stone sober interesting
yeah very straight edge gay edge sorry
yeah that's right